foreign
hold on
everybody wait
i need to crack into the mainframe
i need to get into the back rooms of the
run servers exploits
everybody concentrating places to help
me hacking in the chat
i'm about to do something that no one's
ever attempted before
and
no one will ever likely
again
this is a very serious endeavor this is
something that
if any anything were to go wrong
i don't think there's any coming back
from this
right now i'm trying to
run an incursion protocol into youtube's
mainframe
it's a very tricky system
lots of fail-safes and lots of
anti-viral programs that could
locate my positions and retroactively
drag my ib and
disable my neurons from the inside out
it's very very intense
why aren't you helping me hack
there is a wealth of content
within the walls of youtube
other people think it's safe it's not
just like we go about our daily lives
thinking that we're safe
in our anonymous homes looking up our
things when there's actually a complete
log of every website you've ever been to
no matter how many times you tried to
delete your history no matter no matter
how many incognito windows you open
it's on youtube servers
i'm not trying to save you from yourself
you'll have to do that for yourself
i'm trying to do this for me
because after so many years of doing
youtube i realized that the best way to
continue doing youtube
is to steal other people's content
if i can get into youtube's mainframe i
can bypass all their copyright systems i
can get in between their firewalls and
actually broadcast their content other
youtubers contents as my own
with no repercussions to myself
but it's like walking on a knife's edge
you fall off
you get your balls cut in half
for those of you who are wondering yes
mavis beacon has prepared me for this
moment this is now a mavis beacon only
youtube channel if you thought that
anything was going to be other than
mavis beacon type videos look at the
skills that it's given me when i said
that mavis beacon was preparing me for
war this is it
but what i'm about to do
beyond this
is so much more than just learning to
type and learning to hack and learning
all the mainframe code
by memory
this is the new generation of youtube
content creation
i am literally going to steal other
youtubers contents
and i'm going to play them
right here
on my stream and i'm going to attempt to
make money off of it you heard that
right i'm going to steal other people's
youtube videos
i'm in
so now
i have in front of me
a youtube video that i've stolen
and there will be absolutely no
repercussions to myself
i can broadcast this live on camera
doesn't matter whose it is
but it's mine now
to watch along
as we enjoy this other youtubers content
as if it were my own
which it now is
y'all wanna
see something funny
the vine of today
sorry
the vine of
2021 is tick-tock i once was like
tick-tock is stupid i don't want to look
at it it's dumb this is now my video and
so today
sent me a list of tick tocks to react to
to try not laughing so this is the
considering it's my content now
okay hi
i'm actually i'm going to uh
i'm going to steal other youtubers
content totally for real not joking
i'm actually doing it welcome to content
thief
uh
i had this idea for a while that i
wanted to do a stream with a night
vision camera and then i had an idea of
what if i just broadcast other people's
youtube videos
and see what happens
so i'm going to do exactly that i'm
going to look at i've been wanting to do
this for a while where i look at other
youtubers try not to laughs and judge
them harshly if they don't make me laugh
so i'm going to do exactly that and if
it doesn't make me laugh then they
weren't funny videos and they if they
laugh such as this guy right here i
don't know who this is but i've stolen
their youtube video i hacked into
youtube's mainframes and i have obtained
this video
um if it makes
this uh
child laugh and
not me that means that they have no
sense of humor and i am the ultimate
victor and this video will be mine
forever um therefore here we go
try not to laugh tick-tock edition
and then if we don't have enough
tick-tocks i'll just show you the
tick-tock likes but i'm cranking please
don't talk if you want to get me to a
million followers thank you so much
if you don't do it i'll cry all right
justin let's see
baby someone who has access to one of
those um text to image things oh jeez
whoops
dropped my banana
that's this is not me actually laughing
i didn't actually laugh i thought it was
kind of
dumb seems like it might have been a bit
of a laugh and you're being a little
defensive about it
seems like you might have thought that
it might have been funny
which would be very bad for you
bad first one's bad what do i get if i
don't laugh at all do i get something
good use hashtag iftalk on twitter i'll
do this again don't do that
but i'll react to things try not to
laugh that you send me hashtag talk
that'll be another video but what do i
get if i don't i literally can't turn up
the volume anymore
this is just how poorly mixed this video
is just because i stole the video off of
youtube servers does not mean that i can
improve it in any way the firewalls
would eject me from the server faster
than i would be able to try to modify
the videos this is a very very delicate
situation where i am stealing other
people's contents if i do anything out
of the norm to modify the files they
will find me trace my ip burst down my
door and murder me
this is a risky operation
don't
try
to put me in any unnecessary danger
you understand
okay good
don't laugh
okay i'm taking this as an actual
challenge now um
so we're first of all our name is called
the bare naked ladies
hell yeah
okay we're off to a rough start that's
going to be pretty hard to market and
sell to
just general america but continue i
understand that i understand that um our
first song is gonna go it's shaking the
chinese the chinese chicken
what do you think about that martha can
you get security in here
first of all wow look at that
already laughing we got chuckles mcgee
over here chuckling up a storm
look at this stupid grin here
pathetic
pathetic i love this dude oh god it's
true it's true
i listened not me but like my family had
bare naked ladies on a lot when i was
younger i don't know why specifically on
road trips i don't know but yeah they
have a song and it goes chicken of china
the chinese chicken i think that might
be the first line god that's good that's
a good tick tock
oh no i've seen this i've seen this i've
seen this and it's so bad
oh my god oh my [ __ ] god it's
horrible why did they give him human
ears that's not what the dog's ears
actually
yeah
don't you ever [ __ ] rev your engine
around my girlfriend again she has
[ __ ] heart problems
that's pretty good
such a naughty little rascal pick it up
pick up the sugar pick it up give it a
taste
naughty monkey no you have to you have
to stir it in
you have to stir it in silly monkey
is this your board what is that yeah
would you mind if i wrote it no i'm
gonna go for it yes
that's pretty good you're gonna mess up
your jeans though that grip tape is
gonna mess up your jeans
i have a feeling something really really
bad is gonna happen look it's so small
it gets small
it's shrinking
how does that happen i don't know it's
tiny
why wouldn't why did it look huge
what the f what it's crazy
what
look it's so small like it's small
that is actually a fascinating optical
illusion i don't know how that happens
look i don't know what to tell you guys
i literally can't make it any louder
turn up your dang volume i'm so tired of
people like it's so quiet it's you have
a volume button
see
my volume don't go up no more it is that
loud
that's it it's shrinking how what you
zoomed out while moving forward uh
they did a push-pull
something really cool about the latin
language that i think not many people
know about is that this scientific name
for the great horned owl is
bubo virginia
i'm lightheaded my iron
oh they're gonna
silly cheese on a dog you gonna put
cheese on the dog what are you putting
cheese on
[Laughter]
i want to do that to somebody
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing what are you
that just got me off guard
yeah i thought this was called
try not to laugh i thought that
excuse me this video that i've uh stolen
from youtube's mainframe it's it clearly
says
it clearly says
try not to laugh
i fail to see is my webcam
transparent
am i fading from reality
am i am i slowly melting away
has youtube caught on to the fact that i
am trying to steal content
there we go
that's better
youtube has no idea what i'm doing
there's no way that youtube could ever
find out what i've got going on here
we continue
what are you doing sir what is that just
milk whatever you you missed so hard you
missed so hard oh
that is so upsetting
what
what sound did their microwave just make
that was weird
hey guys i'm in new york city just
hanging out
who is that who who are both what's
happening okay so i'm gonna need a
second here to clear my throat i'm just
getting over it cold but i'll give y'all
a little hint of what i can do
i
[Music]
i'm doing pretty well on this don't
laugh so far
wait what did you just say
i'm sorry let's back let's let's rewind
the tape can you play that back for me
let's see something here i'm gonna go
the scoreboard
where's that scoreboard here it is
if you see
we have four laughs three no laugh one
scream three pity laughs one
flabbergasted upset over spilled milk
tick tocks that almost got me fired
i believe
mr um uh
mr uh
mr
crane gameplays uh i believe that um
you're not doing too good
if the scoreboard is anything to say
about that
hey guys
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
night vision goggles oh that'd be
awesome
i want a gun
i need a gas mask
that stick looks like a gun
i want it
i want a knife this is very true it's
very very true i don't like that [ __ ] on
fire a sword is a must i need i need a
sword i do want to see i need a full
plate of armor if i'm getting a sword
i want a [ __ ] flamethrower i want a
flamethrower or a bullwhip oh
that'd be awesome that would be pretty
okay yeah the night vision i feel called
out about the night vision considering i
am currently doing a stream with night
vision this is actual night vision
um
here i'll turn the night vision off
never mind it doesn't look any different
it's very dark in here it just uh it's
on auto exposure so it it compensates
or it's very dark in here there's just i
can't turn off my monitors or else i
wouldn't be able to see so there's night
vision
so i actually have night vision on and
uh yes it's a must also i almost bought
night vision goggles for uh a wedding
present for my friend i bought hip night
vision goggles i bought him like five
hundred dollar night vision goggles
and he loves them this filter to see it
oh it's this dude i [ __ ] love this
dude i love him
i love him so much on my tick tock i
have some of his stuff liked let's go
through some of my like tick tocks
because we've got time justin i didn't
laugh at many of those
i don't know who justin is but um you
need to stop lying
the lies are really starting to mount up
considering this is my video now and
i've stolen it um
i have higher standards of truth-telling
on my channel
uh so i'm gonna need you to tell the
truth from now on learn more about my
humor anyone else been like
unable to stop saying
wonky slash at any possible moment yeah
yeah
let me reiterate this is one of ethan's
first
likes
on his tick-tock
so my friend just showed me this website
where i don't remember you can put your
mouse on the screen
and it will give you an image of someone
pointing at your mouse
that's so good oh hold on i want to go
to there
[Laughter]
it's so good
oh that is a very very funny website
i'm uh i'm gonna pause this
current
thievery
and i'm going to
thieve even more content because the
content that i just saw being consumed
and enjoyed i am now going to consume
i'm going to find the finger pointing
website
i hope i don't find the
pornographic version or something like
that
okay i found it
huh
[Laughter]
this might be the
[Laughter]
all right this is a pretty good website
this is a really good website guys this
might be
a really good website
[Laughter]
i am really really really impressed
oh boy that is fantastic
oh god
they're pointing beneath me and i got
this
hey
oh [ __ ]
i love it wait a minute
that one's uh it's kind of it's kind of
pointing there okay enough of that
back to the stealing of the content
god this is so good chances of being
killed by a toddler are low
but never zero
[Laughter]
merry
christmas nonna and marco
oh thank you nona
put some money in there
[Laughter]
it's so true follow me follow me we have
a lot of important things for you
no keep following me
don't leave it's right around the corner
i'm a stone on her day off
[Music]
oh
follow me follow me we have a lot of
important things for you
no keep following me
to leave
i'm a stone on her day
it's one of those things where you don't
you know any part of it and then it just
keeps going
[Laughter]
[Music]
tonight we celebrate the birth of jesus
christ of nazareth in a town called
bethlehem
of course that's only if you're a
follower of the christian faith
radical leftist socialists like aoc and
alan o'mara would have you believe that
a giant man with a beard is going to
invade your home
leave presents for your children and
family
a giant man with a beard wearing a red
suit
now why is that now why is that the only
person i can think of with a giant beard
[Laughter]
it's karl marx
it's so spot on
[Laughter]
grinch baby oh it's so good all right
well
well
oh sorry let me let me this is my video
now so i have to take ownership over it
hold on
i'm getting light-headed i need to go
eat something you should eat something
too have you been drinking water today
did you take your medication let me know
in the comments oh good [ __ ] thank you
guys so much don't forget use hashtag
send me your funniest tick tocks and
i'll do another one of these thank you
guys so much for watching hope you
enjoyed if you did
and
all that thing whatever the hell that
was was uh like this
subscribe
go listen to distractible and go my
favorite sports team i am doing this not
for generous purposes i am a content
thief i am full ownership of that i am
doing this for money
i am doing this to steal other people's
content to make easy money that is why
i'm doing it
subscribe
to further my endeavors to thieve more
content
and like this video so more people can
be here so i can further thieve other
people's content and make more money
understood
i'm glad we're clear on this
now on to the next victim
one moment
[Music]
so
[Music]
i need to re-establish my connection to
youtube's
servers if i use the same ip address
every
more than once every two minutes then
they're going to trace my location and
i'll be gone in an instant an air strike
straight from youtube mystery youtube
himself will be dedicated right to my
ass and i can't have that this stream
gets cut out i'm dead
i'm also implanting kill codes in
youtube servers so if they do find me at
least i'll take them down with me
i need everyone else to help me hack
this
server in chat so that i can find my
victim if you guys
in chat hack
wink wink
and help me find my next victim wink
wink i'll be able to hack sooner
winky wing could wink am i making myself
clear to you
i have to be making myself clear to you
if there's any kind of interruption in
our communication if we don't know
exactly what we're going to be doing
here wink wink wink
then youtube's going to be on my ass
and my ass is going to be grass my ass
is gonna be gone
oh i know what i've got i've got it
i'm in
i've done it
another successful hack
as if there was any danger which there
is if i were to mess up at all at any
moment
[Music]
i would be done for
and all of this would be for nothing
hello
i just wanted to leave you a message
letting you know a little more about the
job
now you've been hired to watch over
markiplier's house yeah he's a big time
youtuber guy have you heard of him
now he's not like other game youtuber
types like your pewdiepies or your
jacksepticeyes no he he loves milk
and frankly i'll tell you something he
can't get enough of it
so uh
i left about three gallons of whole milk
in the basement or was it two
i don't know there should be enough to
keep him satisfied for the night or at
least i hope
but if he runs out of milk he gets well
we don't need to go into all that so uh
be careful for all you know
also
his house is ran on milk energy so you
only have so much power for the night
but you should be okay
just keep checking the cameras and only
close the doors of absolutely necessary
hello everybody i'm markiplier
i actually have wanted to do this for a
long time and everyone has said that
it's a very bad idea i want to download
this video i want to redo the voices and
i want to upload it to my channel
without ever asking for permission so
i'm going to do that right now
oh
hello everybody my name is markiplier
i literally have wanted to do this for
so long i
oh you silly god
i really i want to actually do this uh
which i will
oh
making history every day
i
still caught this to this day oh so hard
making history every day
don't
credit him ask for permission
i'm sorry did i stutter in the title of
this
the title of the video is stealing other
youtubers content
what part of that made you think that i
was in any way apologetic about
everything that i was doing because i'm
not i'm here to steal content and i'm
here to profit off of it
i'm not doing this because i'm moral i'm
not taking any stance about this i am
simply stealing other people's content
this is content thief and i'm stealing
it
there's no guise of hiding it with
reactions or whatever
i'm straight up stealing other people's
content and there's not a goddamn thing
youtube can do to stop me
i'm hacked into their servers i'm so
deep inside their mainframes i'm so far
behind their firewalls that there's
nothing they can do
i'm like a ghost
in the system
and they'll never trace me
they'll never find me
never
plus it's a it's a fact that if you have
night vision then you are officially uh
you abstain from crime
that's actually a fact it's that holds
up in court if you have night vision on
you can't be convicted of any crime
100
you absolutely cannot be convicted of a
crime that
you can take my word on that one
don't take my word off so sexy
[Laughter]
oh
you silly cow
you have all the milk don't you you have
all the myths
so hard being me
the crowd screams
they scream for me
glory comes at such a heavy price
this is such good lines in this one it's
such good lines
i still caught them to this day i still
quote them to this day
oh you silly cow
you mean to tell me that you haven't
liked and subscribed
you think that i won't steal your
content
[Laughter]
oh you silly cow
i'm making history every day
it doesn't mean that it's good history
i really do want to just
redub it
i would have gladly done the voices
anyway all right
that's now mine
officially that's now mine
i've stolen it
now on to the next victim
i'm in
sorry
i'm in
i've done it
some may think that i'm starting to
become cocky but uh when you're as good
as me at hacking into youtube's
mainframe at this point
there's really nothing that you can be
afraid of
i've protected myself i've used
youtube's firewalls to build my own
firewalls
impenetrable barriers of fire
mr youtube can't get a trace
if he tries to fire one of his
air-to-ground missiles on my ass he will
just only miss and hit some innocent
bystanders
and he would want that for all the glory
that youtube is they do have some kind
of a moral backbone and that is their
weakness
i don't have any morals
i'm the content thief
and i'm here to steal again
and i'll do it again and again
until i'm satisfied
and let me tell you
i'm not satisfied
i've got it
it's in hand
i found it
tick tock
not even mr septicae
is
this content is now mine
i have claimed it as my own
videos or as some people would like to
call it the new age vine vine is dead
and it will never ever be replaced how
dare you say that get that dirty filth
out of your mouth but
the wine was okay
tick tock is becoming such a gigantic
phenomenon way bigger than i ever
thought it was going to be i thought it
would just show up it would die off and
then it would go away like everything
else trying to replicate vine but it's
here to stay it's a child that no one
wanted but you have to deal with anyway
and when i went to vidcon this year they
were entire party you know i respect
tick tock because it steals all of
everyone's personal information
also some of the videos are funny and it
has
enabled
a new generation of content creation
which is pretty cool
but at the same time it does steal
literally all of your data which is the
thing i most respect about it you know
the thing about like enabling creativity
among people i love the fact that it
steals literally everything about your
personal data
that is cool
he's
absolutely filled with tick-tockers he
said tick-tock only got good when it
starts to replicate what vine was that's
just an absolute fact okay okay i laugh
at everything all the time so now is a
chance
to steal myself
i've already stolen yourself
become
warrior nothing is funny not even this
hilarious
yellow floppy banana
[Music]
okay
this might actually be a lot harder than
i thought it was gonna be i didn't think
anything was gonna make me laugh
that no that doesn't count i'm laughing
at myself
smiling does not count either it's only
laughing all right
smiling my account
but not in my videos my videos they
don't count definitely i thought these
were going to be really bad
but god damn it these might actually be
funny okay okay okay
whoa
joe's not here
that wasn't funny okay
he started off good
yeah me in the first half i'm not gonna
lie and then he came in with that is
that what tic-tac is
it's just kids making older people feel
uncomfortable am i too old for this now
will i not get it show the weapon
oh god this is a terrible idea
this is an awful idea
oh my god
what was that what was he trying to get
into his mouth is that hit him in the
mirror that probably would have knocked
out his teeth jeepers man be careful out
there kids
split his glasses right in half all
right no i didn't laugh no no that was
funny i was amazed i was shocked i was
disgusted i was every other emotion
except laughter is laughter and emotion
yes it is get your pot off the table
[Music]
it's not funny it's not funny it's
mildly amusing it'll make me do a little
but not laughter
it'll be a cold day in hell before i
laugh in a jacksepticeye video don't
even told me that these um plates right
here don't break
not that funny not that funny okay
not that funny i'm not laughing at that
if i laugh at that then comedy is dead
and life is over
all right there's only top tier jokes
allowed on this channel i have never
made a joke that's bad it's all good i'm
not laughing at it no
i just found out
that my sister is pregnant
[Applause]
son of a [ __ ]
why is incest funny to me
i knew where i was going i knew exactly
that that's what he was going to say
and i still almost laughed at it
but not quite
did you know one out of three hoses mad
i'm not mad i'm not mad
i'm mad
do they leave me
yourself that didn't count
oh my god i wish i had teachers like
that when i was in school why is all my
why is all my teachers lame why was none
of my teachers hoes mad
who's mad all the time i'm mad i'm mad
that my teacher wasn't like that i had
crap teachers that just got mad at me
because i was a dumbass okay those ones
i feel like are not the top quality ones
i've never looked at the tick tocks in
these videos i know everyone at home
right now is saying like jack those
aren't even the funny ones
all right
so i'm saying that those aren't even the
funny ones i haven't even gotten close
to laughter then again i expunged all
joy in my soul to become the heartless
bastard that steals other people's
content
that brings me joy we're going to look
at this one this was uploaded in
february and has 15 basically 16 million
views so if this isn't funny you all
need jesus
yo clifford's mailman ain't got no
business being that thick
[ __ ]
okay these are these
i feel like every time i've looked at i
try not to laugh at you i've always felt
like it's probably very easy not to
laugh if you just stand there and go
eventually you'll get through it
just mentally go somewhere else but i
can't do it everything is funny to me
bath time my least favorite time of the
night
sorry i just had to wash my hands before
getting in
[Music]
oh just anger the laughter away the
opposite of laughter is anger
that's why my dad never found anything
funny
punch the air punch the air i have i
have way too much laughter built up in
me i'm a
i'm a laffy taffy
i can't i'm not going to be able to make
it through this this video is 20 12
minutes long and i'm 30 seconds in
don't eat the packing peanuts
what
what was that
that just that's not a laugh all right
i i swear to god i wasn't gonna hate you
i wasn't gonna gesture that i would
never gesture to hit you i would i would
don't flinch
don't flinch
don't flinch
did you flinch two for
flinching don't flinch
i'll steal your content there's a very
blair witch at the moment right now
i would do it
i'll punch you right in the face
and then i'd steal your content
i would 100 do that
would never use violence to overcome
bad emotions
but what the [ __ ]
who thinks of these things why are you
just sitting in a box of packing peanuts
that's epic
oh my there's a little [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] snacks again
low effort low tier
i'm not a little [ __ ]
did you flinch
i know that for a fact so you're wrong
can't you read
forbidden rice
okay
okay i feel like i feel like i'm ready
to laugh i feel like these would make me
laugh all the time
but there's pressure on me there's
eyeballs on me you're watching me i feel
judged if i laugh at something too easy
don't do that
do that
i don't know why i'm
i'm like crime lord
at the moment encouraging people to do
crimes
don't do that
if you do do that disavow any knowledge
that i said to do that i only encourage
the stealing of content actually i do
not encourage the stealing of content i
steal the content
and that is all
don't do that that's a terrible idea i
airplane toilets are scary enough as it
is already i'm always afraid that i'll
be sitting down and i'll go to reach for
the toilet paper and accidentally elbow
the button and then all of a sudden all
of me is all of out there i'll just be
sucked out like opening up a hole in a
watermelon and sticking a hoover into it
and just sucking all the insides out
that is actually true that would happen
so i don't know if you realize how much
danger you're in if you're in an
airplane toilet and you accidentally
press the flush
you just better hope you're not making a
perfect seal on the toilet seat with
your ass because you will be sucked out
from the outside in
from the inside out
from the inside out of the plane and
yourself
did you flinch
that was a lie by the way i don't want
it also why would you mess up
you could have broken the airplane
toilet i'm i'm too old for this
now did they think that that was the
toilet making the noise or the thing
that it was you making the noise did you
leave the toilet and everybody in the
plane was like are you okay
[Music]
kids are so
weird is she trying to choke herself
stop
what was
the [ __ ] face oh my god
when i was a kid
i would take uh and this is when i was
like five i would take spaghetti
and i would hold one end of it
and i would swallow the other
and i would just
i would swallow it down
and then i would pull it back up out
i was not a smart kid
i can't say for certain if i'm a smart
adult
literally
and this is the same era of me
that would swallow that would play a
contest to see how many
chef boyardee ravioli i could swallow at
once
i was not a smart kid
what was the reason for recording this
at all
no that wasn't the left damn it
i'm not alone live okay hey bro kyle um
my mom said that your mom just died so
you're staying at us
um
but
she's bringing home taco bell or i can
tell to bring them dominoes
oh my god that acting is so good
that looks exactly like a real kid
is he a kid
i get asked all the time how tall are
you i'm going to tell them i'm six i'm
like wow that's so cool you must be so
good at basketball and you can reach
change off high shelves but yeah being
610 is cool but like there are also some
issues with being successful
[Music]
oh my god that was perfect for being
tiring oh
no yeah i mean i i know all about that i
know it's not funny because i know
exactly what it's like to be a super
tall dude you know
i've walked into the room and i have to
be like
watch out
when i was a child
i tried to play a game where i jumped on
the bed and there was a ceiling fan over
the bed
and i would bounce on the bed when the
fan was on and i tried to get my head
through the gap it was on the lowest
setting
and i was trying to jump up
in the gap of the fan blades
you know so i wouldn't hit the fan
blades
i hit the fan blades
i broke the fan
okay so you're just gonna put your
finger in
whoa
you know why does that
why because you're adopted
that's not funny
i don't know why i'm laughing it's not
funny it's not funny
you ever get that where
you're trying to hold in the laughs that
at some point
the dumbest [ __ ] makes you laugh i think
i'm trying not to laugh at a funeral
right now
[Music]
oh okay that was good i like that i know
how to play that on piano now
i can't do it for you here
let's boom
oh that is exactly something i would do
this boom
this boom
silly the laughs out jack
come on
okay
let's enhanced
hold on
i can't zoom anymore
let's take a look at this what we're
looking at
hmm
all right cool just want to see
i see
an eagle
what do you see
it's a rorschach test
it's a beautiful eagle
flapping its wings
enjoying freedom
soaring through the skies
peering down
at the natural splendor below
it's a majestic eagle
soaring between the rocky mountains
gliding over the water
it was beautiful
oh it's a penis
oh
[Music]
scared sometimes i carry my floppy
banana in my pocket and everyone's like
god almighty what's wrong with you the
cool thing she can still do a heel
stretch after like four years of not
cheering
oh i feel like i can smell that one from
here that has some stank on it
that was a wet one you need to go change
your underwear right now take a shower
as well
why did you do it why did you do it
that's that's clever that's very clever
i like that one
why did you do it why did you do it
that is very funny
very clever i like that one that was
dumb hey how can you tell if the pasta's
ready just throw it on the wall if it
sticks it's
ready [ __ ] maybe two more minutes
[Laughter]
i did not see where that one was going
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
ah
[Laughter]
[ __ ] maybe two more minutes
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
my god goddamn
but
[Music]
that was pretty funny that's pretty
funny that's pretty funny all right you
know it was uh
i wasn't sure if there was gonna be
anything funny here but it seems like
the uh the mr um uh
uh
maybe
maybe this was worth stealing after all
so uh
pretty happy about this a good find a
good find a good find for my collection
but now
it's time for the ultimate thievery
this is thievery beyond theory this is
actually probably illegal um
so i'm going to do it
because i am the content thief
so
truth be told
this actually is kind of questionable
and i'm going to have to answer for this
tomorrow when i do this thing that i am
about to do
um i'm joking because the content that
i'm about to steal
you can't get this content unless you
pay for it
or procure it through uh
unsavory means
but i'm always willing to stoop lower
than anyone's willing to stoop before
nothing will stop me from procuring the
content with which i crave
i will steal any content from any place
anywhere at any time and there's nothing
that anybody can do
to stop me
no no no this is beyond youtube i need
to stop hacking into youtube surfers or
else they're going to be on to me
they've already started to put in
subroutines that are taking down my
firewalls that i stole from them
my
retroviral anti-killer programs are all
being dismantled on the codular level
so i need to get out of the youtube
servers
but my next target is a website with
which they do not have the same kind of
securitized resources that youtube does
i infiltrated this organization long ago
starting from the bottom and slowly
working my way up the ladder the chain
of command is broken where i have
cracked it and i will not apologize for
anything i'm about to do
you heard that right
i infiltrated corridor digital and i am
about to steal their content that is
behind the paywall on their website
content that is not on their corridor
crew channel or their corridor digital
channel
i'm going to show you things that no one
has ever seen without paying for it on
the website
this actually
will probably be unsavory and i will
have to answer for this but i'm going to
do it and no one is going to stop me
because i cannot be stopped even now i
am completely anonymous you don't know
my identity and you don't know who i am
you don't know where i've come from and
you don't know where i'm going
the sheer number of firewalls that
protect me would boggle your mind
no i'm actually i'm actually going to
show you stuff on the website
i am
stealing other people's content today
one moment please
so this is the corridor crew website
i am logged in i'm a bang member and uh
this is
one of many things oops
sorry i thought my stream went down for
a second the sheer number of firewalls
protected me though
so anyway
literally my browser crashed over on the
stream window but it's okay that was one
of my retro antiviral programs taking it
taking it for me
really took it for me
yes so this is the
exclusive content the crew cuts that you
cannot see anywhere else
i've been with them for about two
months now and as you can see
there's a certain someone here on this
website
look familiar
yes
i've been in videos
behind a paywall
that you did not even know about
i've been there
for two months
working in the background
i've been the corridor crew intern for
two months and many of you didn't even
know
i helped them film videos
i helped build this nerf finger in fact
there i am
i used my engineering expertise yes
expertise i said it
to build that
help build that i didn't build it all
myself
i've helped them with their video ideas
i've helped them with their thumbnails
and just today
i was featured
in a video the concept of which i came
up with
this is all true
many of you may not have known this but
that nerf finger
i hope and make that happen
but that's not what i'm here to show you
i'm here to show you content that i can
steal
and this is content that i not only
stole
but that you can't get on the normal
youtube channel
i will show you i will show you
markiplier versus donkey
i'm gonna show to you and then next week
when another video comes out featuring
my own mother
on this very channel
i will steal that as well
i swear
on my life
i will steal it
anyway
let's watch this
i literally did not ask permission to do
this so if you think that this is some
bit to uh promote anything of corridor
or talk about how i'm on the show no
this is actually a video that i don't
think you can watch without paying for
their website subscription so i'm
showing this to you and i have not asked
any permission to do this at all
period
so uh let's watch you know i used to be
an intern here at corridor when i first
oh wait a minute interesting
is that
drm
started out
is that drm you can't see the video
are they trying to protect it
from rebroadcasting
that's clever
that's clever
they're trying to prevent me from
stealing this content
clever
interesting
i gotta turn off
hardware acceleration you say
oh
alrighty then
i'll do just that
actually
one moment
i probably get a yeah that's right one
second don't you worry about a thing
i got some hacking to do
there we go
easy as pie
you know i used to be an intern here at
corridor when i first started out in
2016.
i don't really have that many memories
of the time but i remember it was fun
welcome to corridor digital but very
soon we are going to be getting a new
intern because the son of a dungeon team
needs some help so every character and
son of a dungeon actually requires a
digital double including the donkey that
means scanning it with polycam thing is
i have a lot of things to scan so i'm
just kind of the intern do it hey in
turn
[Music]
i feel pretty good it's not an honor to
be here when i saw they had an
internship open i was just like
it's for me i'm 100 confident
usually whatever i do the first time i
tried it works out really well
do you want me to keep talking
how long does it take to process
it's done
i'm gonna take this to run good luck
with that he's busy
i'm gonna ask you a question and this
really does dictate whether you know me
or not
do you think i actually stood there
for 10 minutes
do you think i'm the type of person who
on the first day in a new space
would do a bit so audacious
without asking anybody
that i would freeze in place as soon as
someone told me to wait and not move for
10 minutes straight
because i did that
and they were extremely weirded out
but i did not [ __ ] move until ren was
done
you ready for me oh oh it's donkey time
donkey time he's really he's very
patient all right let's see your scan
let's see your scan let's um
dude turn the tail into the leg he's a
tripod he looks rotting dude he's got a
blade nose careful
i don't think this is usable dude
so it looks like you did this using an
automatic make sure that the images are
as crisp useless you want to make sure
there's parallax there's too much donkey
for your vertical space maybe go a
little tapping to focus before snapping
the image has saved me more often than i
was saying in his inane rambling is that
you need to understand your subject
you need to understand everything about
it you need to understand the curves
all the different nuances that you need
to capture because how can you capture
something if you don't understand it
i was reading between the lines of what
he was saying
this is a donkey
i'm applying everything i've learned
don't use auto mode take pictures that
are spaced out with enough parallax try
to fit the donkey in the full frame if
you can't fit the donkey go dutch tap to
focus
i don't think tapping does anything i'm
not gonna lie it doesn't seem to be
changing if i tap up there it's not like
it focuses anywhere else i don't think
ren knows what he's talking about most
of the time i think he somehow deluded
himself into believing that that was
actually going to make a difference and
in fact it did not i'm going back to
auto
question everything that wren says
did you finish oh it's uploading oh
yeah
and this is the one that you did with
manual
uh
mm-hmm
[Music]
don't look at that part you notice how
the details here are not super clear ac
is making the baskets kind of wobble
that could introduce problems so like
this basket wobbling like this is a
problem uh probably
do i have to do it again
you might have to do it again
okay but i think you can do better i
think some of your shots it was pulling
from stuff that i was going auto
i wasn't tapping to focus dude
i had doubts about everything that you
said and i thought that you going manual
was your last clinging on to some
creative attachment to what was being
made and i thought it was a desperate
move and i thought you were pathetic for
it
we talked about this dude
manual
manual automatic only works if you've
got too much light
we don't have too much light inside
so you have to do it manual
you know what's funny about that is uh
in the most recent video they just went
up on the corridor crew channels today
they did have too much light you
remember my flashlight video where i
made a video where i was in a dark room
with night vision
i had a light a flashlight that did a
hundred thousand lumens so i want you
all to understand something how my brain
works because this actually is an
important look into it because even i'm
just realizing this right now the last
time i did a night vision video was when
i did a night vision video
where i did a flashlight
in a dark room today there was a light
video that was inspired by my idea that
i did a flashlight video i did not
realize that i connected this in my head
to do a live stream that was also night
vision i don't know how this relates to
stealing content that probably is
something tied into my childhood or
something like that but psychologically
speaking i think i subconsciously wanted
to do a night vision live stream today
because
the inspiration for corridor cruise
video today was based on a video where i
did it with night vision
can hmm show me how we'll do it together
the vibe is so weird
so the name of the game when you're
trying to do photogrammetry is you want
sharp images the downside to using
automatic is that it only detects when
you move so snap in all the photos while
you move and that's why you have the
option to do manual captures so you can
kind of steady the camera and take the
photo you won't get motion blur
i have found that there are images that
i thought were in focus but weren't so i
always try to make a habit of just like
constantly just tapping between them it
usually only makes a difference when
you're that close i see that's good
advice
[Music]
so let's compare what these scans look
like i actually took several very
specific photos around the face that's
why i have a little bit more detail on
the head and the eyes than your scan
does however if we zoom out both of
these scans look identical i think he
did it this is pretty solid
i mean we'll probably use mine
but yours is totally usable
are you thirsty
that makes it so you're watching
but you're unable to control it because
i think you should treat everyone on any
kind of hierarchical structure with the
same amount of respect because it's just
good human decency just because you're
at a certain point in some kind of uh
corporate ladder doesn't make you any
more or less valuable than any other
person
[Music]
this isn't what i thought it was when
you watch the videos you see all these
special vfx all this polish and then you
get to the studio and you see all of
these inefficiencies everywhere
they just pile everything on the intern
they give everything for me to do and
then i have to do all of it and i'm not
learning anything except for the fact
that there seems to be a problem lurking
deep at the core
he's gonna be a great intern you work
all day go back to your dorm and since
you can't afford a mortgage
well
i did die that day
but apparently i got better i don't
really have a lot of memory i've
actually started to dig deep into the
corruption that lies at the heart of
corridor and being on the inside this is
why i don't feel bad stealing this at
all
because as you can see through the
various episodes of the crew cuts season
two yes there's also a season one
there's probably hundreds of vlogs that
you have not seen that are on this
website
you can get it by subscribing on the
website corridordigital.com but
you can see my investigation continues
beyond just this video
i start to explore the darkness lurking
deep within the soul of corridor
and let me tell you
that's terrifying down there
there are some things that i wish i had
not seen there are some things that i
wish i could forget and there's some
things that i don't think i ever will
that place changed me
forever
and i don't know who i'll be when i'm at
the end of it but you know me i will see
this through to the end
i've changed for the worse but also i've
become stronger for it
all of this amounts to an idea
where i will dismantle corridor from the
inside out brick by brick i will take
what they think is theirs and i will
show them in their face
so that they can confront their own
darkness inside of them yes
the cd on the belly of corridor is
disgusting
this past week of loan i have dug deeper
than anyone in that studio ever has into
their past
both metaphorically and physically
there are some things that are so
incredibly wrong
you would not believe
no actually uh i spent this last week um
cleaning out corridor um i've been
taking it upon myself
uh to rebuild their workshop um because
their workshop is a goddamn nightmare
this is actually not a joke not a bit at
all their workshop is [ __ ] hell
and uh it just so happens that like my
latest hyper fixation kind of coincides
with this so it was a perfect storm my
adhd brain kind of like went into
hyperdrive
um because my buddy john was in town and
he was helping me with a nerf turret
build and if you don't know about any of
what that's about you got to watch the
corridor crew videos i've been a part of
like that's the only thing um but long
story short he was help he was helping
me build a weapon of nerf destruction
that would tear down the walls of
corridor forever this is all a true
story but there actually is something
that is
absolutely terrifying that's going to
come out in a video um
so
this is not a joke i actually built
their workbench but to do that that
wasn't even the first step the first
step was clearing everything out because
number one it's a bunch of youtubers
doing you know
regular old uh whatchamacallit uh videos
content creation of which i'm stealing
uh but i gotta tell you about the boom
boom room okay
i'm
the boom boom room is exactly as it
sounds it is a room
that probably could have exploded and
this was just there
it was there
it was
it was there um so the boom boom room
was kind of this it wasn't the first
thing that kicked all this off but it
was the thing that really really kicked
off the entirety of it um
[Music]
basically this was a room in the very
back of the studio in the in the in the
most isolated part next to the
electrical boxes the fuse boxes now this
is an important detail you know what a
fuse box is it's a it's a panel with
fuses in it where all of the amperage
going into that building all the power
going into that building runs through
those boxes because the fuses are there
to protect in case of overages but that
doesn't mean that it's perfectly safe
they can still uh short circuit they can
still fry the fuses can be overloaded
and things can go terribly wrong there
and it can spark
so that's important to remember the
other thing in this room that's
important to remember that
this is where they stored a lot of their
special effects so there's vfx which is
visual effects and their special effects
was physical effects like fire
and gun powder
and fireworks
and gasoline
yes
they had
gasoline propane tanks fireworks gun
powder flash powder a box of fireworks
with a box of matches in the same box
next to two 200 amp
electrical panels
in the farthest back part of their
studio
this is all true
all true
so i took it upon myself to make it my
absolute goddamn priority to clean out
that workshop because i have seen
electrical i've seen fuse boxes actively
spark before and they have a lot more
employees in that office than they used
to and
they short the few they blow fuses all
the time
literally
you might in an alternate reality if i
had not done what i did last week you
could have at some point in the future
seen a headline
where
entire corridor office
[ __ ] explodes
tense why it was called
by my buddy john
the boom boom room
because it could have gone boom boom
so this past week i've been cleaning
that out literally i have been cleaning
it out with uh
uh
jason evan john tyler was helping out um
you know nat from corridor was helping
out it was a it was top priority number
one but because i like to do things
right it took a lot more time because i
wanted to renovate the workshop at the
same time because it was very difficult
to work in the workshop in the state
that it is not many of you people know
probably but i used to build decks when
i was in high school for the last two
years of high school i worked as a deck
builder which basically means that i did
carpentry i built decks i framed them i
put them up and down i didn't know
exactly all the terminology but i knew
how to swing a hammer and i knew how to
fire a nail gun and i knew how to carry
lumber and i knew kind of where to put
it and how to make a cut right
so it was really fun
after the boom boom room was taken care
of that was that was the first thing
that we did um it was really fun because
i physically built
their workbench and i don't have a
picture of it right now but it'll come
out in a video in the future i built
their workbench using my in my craftsman
uh carpentry knowledge um
i physically built it i actually built
it and then all of a sudden i had this
memory flooding back into my head like
oh yeah i can do carpentry oh yeah i can
make things
oh yeah power tools like i can actually
use them so many times in my life i've
just like totally forgotten that i know
how to use any tools so guess what i did
guess what i just irresponsibly with my
money did and this is so funny because
when i redid the workshop i didn't want
to buy any new wood because wood is
crazy expensive right now so i uh we
tore down all the previous woods and we
used almost entirely reclaimed wood
which just means the wood that was lying
around before i did the forbidden
carpentry technique of lengthening wood
right you know they say with hair you
know you can only cut it can only go
shorter you can't really go longer uh
well
it's kind of the same with wood working
but i pulled off the maneuver that was
only passed down from generation of
carpenter to carpenter of lengthening
wood making it longer
and so that's what i did for this
workbench and it's totally fine it is
very strong there it's a four by four
that i lengthened it's totally fine it's
square it stands up straight it's strong
it's flat it's great
and then i cut a notch out of the top of
it but that doesn't change any of the
strength
but guess what i did irresponsibly after
that moment i bought
so many power tools
i bought so many
i know
i sh i don't have a need
for them
but i bought so
goddamn many power tools
i bought and
i don't know how you feel about this
particular brand right but i bought
exclusively ryobi
now this isn't gonna mean a lot to a lot
of you and i know that a lot of you are
like oh power tools whatever it doesn't
matter but look at me in the eyes when i
say
my god was it a deal it was a [ __ ]
deal all right they had i don't even
know how they were selling it at the
prices they were but they were so i
bought ryobi i'm not sponsored if they
want to sponsor me [ __ ] get it they
got a [ __ ] ryobi bug zapper that i
bought they got a ryobi power washer
they got a ryobi toothbrush they got a
ryobi armpit hair removal system they've
got everything is
the same bat it's insanity i swear the
people in the ryobi r d department are
just pounding lines of coke just
yeah i gotta make a dog washer battery
powered it's incredible okay it's
incredible i don't know why i did this i
apologize or like i said hyper fixation
adhd it happens yes i'm still on
medication
it's fine
it's just for sometimes i get excited
about things okay and i'm not
apologizing for it just like i'm not
apologizing for stealing all of this
content if you go to corridordigital.com
you can subscribe and watch all the rest
of it i just showed one what's the crime
you're gonna throw me in jail for that
no you can't even catch me anyway
what was the question right
but it's been fun it has been so it was
oh man it was a deal oh my god it was a
deal but i couldn't stop i couldn't stop
because i'm normally very frugal
sometimes but other times i'm just like
oh it's a deal i'm like my mom i'm too
much like my mom
oh no
oh
no
anyway
a battery-powered power washer by the
way yeah no it's okay
yes yes
yes i've
it's not the ass pills that's not what
they are
but i'm still on them no i'm not off my
meds
it's
it's called the starus it's it's star
it's got star there's no asses
it's not ass pills they go in your mouth
okay
cool good cloud we
caught up with that i still haven't done
a video i've been meaning to do it for a
long time where i actively like
in a more responsible way talk about
like adhd and my adhd and i'm not saying
that anything i'm doing today is in any
way related to that okay this is not
what this is about i'm just and
genius
i wasn't gonna say an idiot i was i'm
just a genius you all these other
creators need to get on my level where
they realize that they don't actually
need to make any content they just need
to steal everyone else's content and
then you get an infinite cycle of
content that you get to reuse over and
over and over and over again right
okay
why am i green because it's night vision
how can i make this any more clear it's
it's night vision i am stealing content
therefore
i need to be in the dark because if i'm
not in the dark then people
are going to
find my location
so it's night vision
all right okay cool
anyway
yes we're recycling we're recycling
content we're recycling
yes yes yes anyway
i was so upset
that you guys
didn't enjoy the mavis speaking videos
i need to have a talk with you guys
we need to have a heart-to-heart
those videos are the best videos that
i've ever made
okay
those mavis beacon videos
they're my pride and joy they are
the best videos i have ever created
and when i
when i realized that you guys did not
enjoy those videos when you did not
watch it i i thought of two paths
i thought of exclusively making this
channel a mavis beacon only channel
just to say
i'm better than you
just to say
i'm better than you
but then i thought against it then i
thought why do i even bother trying to
put any kind of originality into
anything i ever do when in all honesty
the true path to success in youtube is
just to steal other people's content
and i chose that path
i chose that path and you know i don't
regret a thing
the only thing i regret
is giving you the quality maven speaking
content that you never even deserved
to think
you work so hard
you work so hard
to make
history every day
and some people are too blind to see the
glory
you silly cow
i smell the calcium in your bones
oh
glory comes it's such a heavy breath i
love that
anyway
um
what was i talking about i had something
else that i actually was very important
that i wanted to tell you
nothing
oh
i need more calcium
i really do want to just download that
video but everyone says it's a very bad
idea and i don't get it if i download
the video and i just redub it just the
parts with my voice
it's and then i re-upload it it's like
i'm honoring him them whoever it is
whoever mr canyon is it's i'm honoring
them right and also who's gonna stop me
who
who's gonna stop me huh
nobody
nobody
it's just a terrible it's not a terrible
idea it's a genius idea because every
idea i have is genius
every single one i mean
literally not there's never been a bad
idea coming out of this head
never not one
ryobi sponsor me or i'm
dead to you you and you're dead to me
anyway
i'm just killing time guys
no it's
transformative
it's transform i'm
transformatizing it i am improving it in
every way possible how can i not make it
better by adding my voice to it my
glorious voice you couldn't even pay for
my voice it's that good it's that pricey
it's that rich
it would be a blessing
it would be a blessing
i'm not good
i always get in these moods where every
time i like i know that i have really
stupid ideas sometimes but it's the
funniest thing like with the mavis
because like i'm not i'm not upset at
all about it what it actually is is like
whenever someone's like
you shouldn't do that it makes me want
to do it so much more i don't know why i
don't know why that is i don't know why
it's not always that's not how i operate
on my day-to-day life i just i'm just
very counter to everything
anyway
so
who am i talking to i'm talking to you
i'm talking to all of you guys
look
it's not
it's not it's not an adhd thing
it's a it's a i i just sometimes feel
the need to turn on the camera and cause
chaos that is that is that is the neat
thing
no i've been doing great though i've
been i've been so busy though i know i
have not been able to get videos up at a
regular way and my editors are screaming
at me to record videos and literally
today i was supposed to record a lot of
videos but i keep getting in these i
keep getting these like
ideas that i for some reason have to
pursue
and this is kind of like this is
something i've actually been embracing
because i do think that
like
creativity comes in bursts right
creativity comes in waves and i'm always
happiest when i'm just able to do
absolute nonsense at any time
like i don't know why i committed to do
a complete overhaul of corridors
workshop last week
and i promised to do it in three days
and that son of a [ __ ] was tough i was
working 12-hour days just hauling things
in and out not even content creation i
wasn't even doing it for videos but i
just wanted to do it like that's that's
what i really like you know if i'm going
to be i'll be i'll be 100 straight up
with you uh with with like this is
actually personal adhd experience
i was on adroll for a very long time and
adderall is very good at making you feel
like you can do things whatever i got a
prescription for it i have adhd i have
been diagnosed with that so i'm not
saying just go out and get it but i do
not like
uh the feeling of being on that
medication
um it felt like being a robot it felt
like um it messes with my sleep it
messes with my mood does a lot of things
having adhd is tough and there's a lot
of different ways to
mitigate that through therapeutic means
um
but lately you know i've just felt more
free
and stuff
and uh it's uh i oh i don't wanna us to
clarify i didn't just like
quit taking that medication i spoke with
my my doctor i spoke with my therapist
and i talked about changing a medication
so what i did was i changed medication
to uh one called the stars that has been
working out very well for me because it
allows me to number one sleep and number
two feel like myself um but also it i
feel more of that
creative side of myself if that makes
any sense at all i i don't talk to a lot
of people about like adhd stuff and and
it's it's never really been something
that i feel i need to make an excuse for
you know what i mean i've never been
apologetic about
like the fact that i have adhd um
it does it come it does hinder my life
in a lot of ways but you know at the
same time i'm not one to like dwell on
it i have it and it's fine i i manage it
as best i can uh but for the first time
in a long time i've
like the past three months i've been
feeling more and more like myself just
like this
being able to
come up with an idea and enjoy it and
pursue it and even if it's tough it's
been very nice so i've been feeling
really really good yes the ass pills
if you don't know what that
joke is about you haven't been hanging
around the members they will never let
that go
yeah no i've been having a great time
but i know that videos have been lacking
it's just because i've been having a
great time with corridor i don't know
how long i'm going to be at corridor um
but i did move a desk over there so i
can make videos while i'm over there so
i can keep up with stuff i do have ideas
for videos that i want to make and i
know that i was supposed to record some
the
this
weekend but i didn't
so we'll see what happens
[Laughter]
but i mean you know that's part of a
that's part of the prize of subscribing
to my channel is uh you never know what
you're gonna get and it's always going
to be some form of chaos but uh
like i said at the beginning of this
who's gonna stop me
right
who's gonna stop me alexian is screaming
i bet i bet i bet but who's gonna stop
me no one no but i've been having a
great time more cool stuff coming soon
and and do check out corridor because i
have been making a lot of videos with
them so a lot of my time has been spent
with them but there is good content over
there you can go to corridor crew or you
can go to corridor digital uh their
website like you can subscribe it's
actually worth it because they got a lot
of good content there even if you just
try it out and like five bucks watch
their whole catalog unsubscribe
afterwards like just give it a try it's
fun i think they got a free trial so um
thank you so much for being here i gotta
go i've got a dinner date with amy and
i'm not going to miss that for the world
so uh you all have a good time now links
in the description for uh distractible
and go my favorite sports team which are
the podcasts that i have with my friends
because i want my friends to be
successful and have a great podcast that
they can call their own
that's the true honest reason
plus it's fun to be able to talk with my
friends so check it out it's good times
have a good day everyone uh spread the
love remember uh don't steal content
leave that to me
i will be the lightning rod of legal
claims i will take the lawsuits i will
i'll deal with all that i have lawyers
and they're probably screaming too so uh
as long as i'm not screaming right all
right i'm gonna go before i get more
legal trouble
later